for the padres making his third start of
the 2020 season
is the 21 year old left-hander from la
habana cuba and adrian moore at home
muncie hits with a man at third and two
gone in a scoreless first inning
walking down the line there with a
scoreless game and two gone that's
mookie betts whoo what a sweeping
breaking ball
big time hook curveball got him swinging
made munchie look bad
bruiser grouderal in his career he's 1-3
with a 3.62 era 21 punch-outs and 27 of
the third innings pitched
now machado at 3 11. got 13 home runs
he's knocked in
40. machado on on two strikes out
swinging
on the changeup up and in and the inning
is over this is empty two out here's aj
pollock
on a 2-0 he drives the ball in the air
to right center field grisham's going
back and pollux leaving the yard
breezing by the palm tree in right
center field
solo home run gives the dodgers the
game's first run
number 11 of the season for aj pollock
two on two out and here's jason castro
and a base heading to right field for
castro from third comes myers
onya's headed for third maybe beyond
betts out there to fire back in o'neill
be stopped
padres have tied the game one to one
jason castro
that's a double to the line of the
corner in right field the bases are
loaded two down
and that'll bring up trent grisham so
already a big moment in the game and
we're just in the second inning tied at
one bases loaded two out
grisham swings and grounds it to first
backhanded by bellinger
jogs to the bag the inning is over
however the padres come up with a run
two hits leave three that's standing in
on the right side
and he grounds it up the middle tatis
dives he'll flip
or roll to second base to get the out
nicely done
great diving play to get there and then
he flips it a few
hops to chronoworth covering it second
for the out
of gavin lux all right max muncie coming
up
lefty against lefty there they go here
it comes muncie swats one down the line
that's a fair ball
into the corner max muncie delivers with
two out
seeger in the score on a max muncie
double that puts the dodgers back in
front
and still two runners in scoring
position with will smith coming up
the 1-2 a check swing tapper along first
luke casey stumbles and throws late and
the dodgers lead
3-1 as turner's into score first and
third two gone here's bellinger
lefty lefty with bellinger first pitch
swinger a little tapper back to the
mound more routine this time for luke
casey his throw to first
is in plenty of time and the top of the
third finally does come to an end but
the dodgers get a couple of runs on a
couple of hits there was an error
we're at the corners for the dodgers two
down and here is will smith
first and third two out the three two is
a fly ball to left center field that
one's well hit
that's going to roll to the wall split
the seam
bed scores easily turner is on his way
home and he'll jog in
safely a two out two run double for will
smith and the dodgers lead at 5-1
for two today struck out swinging and
grounded back to the mound
bellinger on one and two swings and
lines one to left field's going to drop
in for a base hit
profar with a throw home smith on the
way he'll make it
and delivering in the clutch is
bellinger he's at second base
dodgers now with a six to one lead
pollock had the home run and then he
struck out on his other at that in the
fourth inning
this ball is hit on the right side this
is corner worth on a two-hopper grab
throw
in time ended it ended it
but still it was three runs that came in
in this inning
chris taylor gavin lux and mookie betts
scheduled to bat here
and the top of the sixth inning for la
with the dodgers on top
six to one that ball's hit to the moon
by chris
taylor how far does it go second deck
and left center
taylor's sixth one of the longest he's
hit
and the dodgers at one it's 7-1
there's justin turner 7-1 dodgers we're
under first and two gone
and a swing and a miss turner strikes
out gets away briefly so they got to
throw him out and they do
two down moreland that first base and it
brings up george some profile
and a drive to right field for profar
bets looking up and it is gone a
two run home run for jerks and profar
his seventh of the year
and the padres get two of them back it's
now seven three la
chipping away
[Applause]
one out here in the eighth and it brings
up manny machado
fly ball center field has kiki hernandez
going back still going at the wall
that's gonna carry out of here home run
for manny machado
14th home run of the year and it's now
seven to four here come the padres
straight away center field here at petco
over the blue padded wall one out one on
and the return of francisco mojita
yank to left taylor makes the catch
not an easy play but chris taylor has a
home run in this game able to make it
up to pro far to try and keep the padres
hopes alive in this game
and a liner into left field for a base
hit onya's coming around
he will score to make it seven to five
profar
drives in a run and the padres will
bring the tying run to the plate
top of the order trent grisham who had
his ninth home run of the year earlier
in the series against clayton kershaw
represents the tying run two gone in the
nine
pops up the first pitch left side and
this should do it max muncie's there
he's got it
and the dodgers say to the padres not so
fast after san diego takes the first
game of the series depot within one and
a half
the dodgers take games two and three to
win the series
and clinch a spot in the postseason